mesdames et messieurs bonsoir 24 heures
après le raid américain manquait en iran
le monde entier se pose mille questions
nous tâcherons de répondre à
quelques-unes en consacrant la majeure
partie de ce journal à une édition
spéciale que vous présenterons louis b
rue et georges bortoli d'où sont partis
les avions américains
comment trois hélicoptères lourds ont
ils pu tomber en panne
nous venons de recevoir à l'instant même
les premières images en provenance
d'iran et qui vous montre les carcasses
des appareils américains voilà tout ce
qui reste en plein désert iranien 300 km
de téhéran de l'expédition lancée par
les américains pour délivrer leur autre
âge de la capitale de l'iran ces images
que la télévision iranienne viennent
nous faire parvenir avec quelque
complaisance et toute la satisfaction
qu'on imagine montre ce qui reste de
huit hélicoptères les uns en bon état
d'autres en panne et un troisième écrasé
avec par un choc avec un gros avions de
transport un c 130 est aussi bicorps les
corps de ceux qui sont morts
accidentellement et que l'expédition
américaine n'a pas réussi à rapatrier
les blessés les américains eux sont
rentrer et l'on dit aussi que les
iraniens se sont empressés de finir de
détruire la plupart des appareils de
peur paraît-il que les américains
reviennent s'en servir alors maintenant
quelles vont être les conséquences de la
sphère en amérique et sur le plan
international
nous proposons une réflexion générale
avec l'aide d'experts sur notre plateau
à maurice couve de murville président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale les 5000 bizarre
avocats écrivains américains
spécialiste des rapports est ouest à
washington le professeur stanley
hoffmann politologue professeur à
harvard et à moscou alexeï c'est émane
journaliste politique à la
radiotélévision soviétique
d'abord quelques faits a pris
aujourd'hui premièrement en iran va
disperser les attaches dans plusieurs
villes pour qu'il soit beaucoup plus
difficile de leur venir en aide
par une action semblable à celle d'hier
demain l'opinion publique américaine est
favorable à carter alors qu'hier on
prédisait le contraire en europe à
moscou enfin on parle de la déraison de
monsieur cartel l'iran eh bien il en fut
évidemment question à la convention du
ps consacrée aujourd'hui la politique
étrangère la plupart des orateurs ont
condamné l'intervention américaine tout
en rappelant que le parti socialiste
avait dès le début condamné la prise
d'otage cela n'a pas empêché jean
françois mitterrand de tenir compte de
l'aspect humain de l'intervention des
états unis d'amérique le droit du pays
bafouée défaire les familles et d'une
façon plus générale la famille
américaine est touché qu'on ne serait la
famille française le droit de délivrer
est pour le moins égal se remettait cela
sans paradoxe audois au droit
d'emprisonner c'est à dire que nous
sommes dans une situation qui ressemble
à la guerre à partir de là
instinctivement je ne critique pas celui
qui veut sauver son frère il n'empêche
pour monsieur mitterrand que l'échec
américain est condamnable puisqu'il fait
peser un risque sur la paix dans le
monde
de plus monsieur carte a entraîné ses
alliés européens dans une politique de
sanctions économiques contre l'iran tout
en déclenchant une opération militaire
il a donc trompé c'est à jour quant à
monsieur rocard il a lui aussi évoqué
l'iran à la fin d'un discours très
théorique sur la social démocratie dans
le monde
discours dans lequel il n'a jamais été
en contradiction avec monsieur me taire
mais notre long combat de socialistes
contre la dictature du chah nous
autorise à dire aux américains que le
souci de revanche du peuple iranien
s'explique même s'il prend des formes
est inacceptable il faut hélas savoir
attendre qu'un pouvoirs publics
respecter naissent en iran une politique
de sanctions
outre sa très grande difficulté
technique on vient de le voir et ça la
condamne déjà ne peut avoir que trois
effet menacé la vie des otages
après tout la sûreté nerveuse
maintenance et de l'iran qu'elle dépend
des feux dé favoriser la renaissance
d'une autorité publique respecter en
iran et puis
pousser l'iran vers le bloc soviétique
c'est tout le contraire de ce qu'il faut
faire il faut parfois du courage pour
reconnaître qu'il y a des problèmes
temporairement insoluble le malin
commençons national du parti socialiste
examinera le calendrier de désignation
des candidats socialistes aux
présidentielles
certains sont pressés comme les chiffres
car assez amer la majorité autour du
musée mitterrand voudrait attendre le
plus longtemps possible
il est probable que le candidat
socialiste ne sera pas désigné avant le
milieu du mois de décembre prochain
mais je baignais ans qui rentrait de
varsovie où il a remis un message de
monsieur giscard d'estaing numéro 1 par
le mc guirec
au cours du discours de politique
internationale qu'il a prononcé cet
après midi à pontoise aux assises
départementales de l'edf a estimé que la
situation était assez grave pour que
l'opposition trouve à mieux à faire qu'à
se livrer à des magouilles c'est son
goût monsieur valls qui a dit qu'elle
est à la disposition de la justice à
laquelle il n'avait rien à cacher
aujourd'hui
l'opposition me prend possible et vise
d'ailleurs d'autres au delà de moi cela
ne trompe personne et je vous dirais que
j'en suis flatté
parce que le dernier homme politique que
certains aient souhaité traîner road
cours c'était le général de gaulle les
députés socialistes et communistes
cherchent à ouvrir des voies redoutable
pour la démocratie
ils prétendent transformer le palais
bourbon en palais de justice politique
instaurer une justice de partie où la
séparation des pouvoirs n'aurait plus
cours ou les citoyens et les élus
seraient livrés au bon vouloir politique
et c'est avec des méthodes juridique de
ce genre que l'on aboutit aux régimes
totalitaires les plus redoutables où les
partis se font justice les uns contre
les autres et le parti communiste le
sait bien
je mets en garde solennellement les
députés et les dirigeants des partis de
liberté contre de tels dangers ou
colloques des jeunes démocrates sociaux
monsieur bernard stasi a souligné
gardons nous aujourd'hui tout
particulièrement d'ironiser sur les
incohérences sur les insuffisances et
sur les râper la politique américaine la
faiblesse des états unis est celle de
l'occident face au temps de la servitude
elle est aussi la faiblesse du camp de
la liberté
il n'y a aucun survivant dans la
catastrophe de l'avion charter anglais
qui s'est écrasé aux îles canaries à
santa cruz de tenerife le bilan est très
lourd 146 morts l'appareil est tombé six
minutes avant l'atterrissage
non loin d'une cité universitaire et une
vingtaine de kilomètres de l'aéroport
sur le flanc d'une colline très boisé la
plupart des passagers venaient de la
région de manchester pour prendre
quelques vacances au soleil ce qui
paraît curieux
première vue c'est que les recherches
sont d'abord orientée vers la mer car
l'on croyait que l'appareil était tombée
dans les eaux les officiels avait même
donné l'ordre à tous les bâtiments
croisant près des côtes de rechercher
l'avion vista après ce résumé de
l'actualité
et bien venant en vo berio à notre
édition spis nous souhaitons vous
proposer une réflexion sur l'état de la
situation internationale et ses
évolutions possibles
nous allons le faire sur trois thèmes la
situation intérieure aux états unis avec
stanley hoffmann en direct de washington
avec jacques séguy les relations entre
les états unis et l'europe avec monsieur
maurice couve de murville ici dans nos
studios
la tension entre l'est et l'ouest avec
samuel bizarre spécialiste des relations
entre l'est et l'ouest et alaixys
hezemans en direct de moscou avec
cheikha bouchard jacques bouchard qui
avait que jean pierre elkabbach patrick
poivre d'arvor et une équipe
plusieurs équipes de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 réalise pour lundi prochain
une journée spéciale sur l'union
soviétique mais il avant d'engager ces
discussions sur les trois thèmes que je
viens d'évoquer les faits lyon y trône
est bien l effet dans la nuit
d'avant-hier à hier le président des
états unis ordonnent une opération
aéroportée de commandos avec comme but
final de tenter de libérer les otages
détenus depuis 174 ans pour des avions
et des hélicoptères lourds de
l'aéronavale américaine nous les avons
vu tout à l'heure
transportant des marines s'envole de
divers lieux et je rejoigne non loin de
tabac ça 300 km au sud est à peu près de
téhéran pour établir d'abord une tête de
pont
mais plusieurs incidents techniques très
graves se produisent alors maurice
werther à partir de là que va t-il se
basterds c 130 ont fait escale dans le
sud de l'egypte hollande se poser près
de tabac ce dans le désert iranien
environ 300 km de téhéran
les hélicoptères et h 53 ont décollé du
porte-hélicoptères nimitz en mer
d'arabie au large du sultanat d'oman
pour aller se poser au même point de
rencontre et de ravitaillement de
abbas les matériels maintenant d'abord
le porte-avions nimitz orgueil de la
flotte tout s'envole huit hélicoptères
rh 53 les plus modernes construits par
sikorsky l'un après l'autre trois de ses
hélicoptères tombe en panne au troisième
la mort dans l'âme le président carter
donne l'ordre d'abandonner l'opération
ce n'est pas tout après la défaillance
technique et mécanique comme devait le
dire monsieur carter c'est l'accident
dans les conditions mal défini un
hélicoptère en pleine retraite tamponne
un c-130 un des six avions gros porteurs
chargés de ramener tout le monde en lieu
sûr il ya eu morts et des blessés les
autres avions ramène les blessés vers
des hôpitaux amis en allemagne
occidentale d'abord aux états unis
ensuite l'avion accidenté et tous les
hélicoptères indemne ou non sont donc
abandonné sur place que nous l'avons vu
tout à l'heure
l'aviation iranienne vient les détruire
de peur dit ont curieusement du côté
iranien que les américains ne revienne
sans service l'emmenant en conséquence
réaction de l'iran
si les états unis recommence d'un raid
semblables les otages seront sacrifiés
et aussi toi une décision on va
disperser les otages dans plusieurs
villes comme cela c'est des états unis
tentaient néanmoins une nouvelle
opération de commando il leur serait
beaucoup plus difficile voire impossible
de réussir a libéré tous les otages
cergy ce fait ces américains sont
prisonniers depuis bientôt six mois
jusqu'à présent ils vivaient ensemble
maintenant ils vont être séparés ce sont
les étudiants islamiques qui viennent de
le décider les otages vont être
dispersées dans différentes villes
d'iran et ils seront placés sous la
responsabilité de la population le
détail de leur transfert sera révélé
ultérieurement
cette mesure de précaution est prise dit
on pour décourager toute autre tentative
américaine d'ailleurs s'il y en avait
une on précisait d'étudiants islamiques
elle entraînerait immédiatement
l'immolation de tous les otages
ce qu'un quant à monsieur palissandre le
président de la république iranienne il
a tenu tout à l'heure une conférence de
presse y assister la famille du marine
team retenu en otage monsieur madame
team ont condamné l'action du président
carter monsieur bani sadr lui a dit que
l'iran ne déposerait pas de plaintes
devant les nations unies
et il a ajouté qu'il était d'accord pour
rendre les corps des soldats américains
tués dans l'opération sans poser de
condition préalable aux états unis après
ces faits voyons comment se présente la
situation maintenant oui mais alors tout
de suite avec georges bortoli les
réactions en france et dans le monde et
particulièrement à moscou à moscou nous
attendent
alaixys hezemans et jacques à bouchard
france mort tommy les jeunes français
ont des réactions qui vont de la
commisération l'inquiétude de
commisération par exemple avec le
quotidien de paris titrait ce matin sous
un portrait de carter
le pauvre et inquiétude par exemple avec
la croix qui titre ce soir carter le dos
au mur du côté officiel le chancelier
schmitt et madame thatcher également ont
exprimé une certaine compréhension à
l'égard du président carter mais avec
des réticences visible du côté officiel
français silence complet bref l'europe
est consterné
l'occident est concerné d'autant plus
consternés d'ailleurs que les américains
n'ont pas vraiment joué la concertation
dans cette affaire avec lance ali quant
aux réactions soviétique et bien vous
l'avais dit il ya jacques bouchard qui
nous est un moscou alors jacques est ce
que vous nous entendez est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de l'atmosphère
politique aujourd'hui à moscou
concernant cette affaire de la tentative
américaine en iran et bien georges
bortoli vous savez que l'union
soviétique avait déjà un sérieux compte
à régler avec monsieur carter au sujet
du potage deux olympiques il est évident
que la sphère de location de commandos
de téhéran contre l'iran n'a rien
arrangé
alors la presse de moscou s'est
littéralement déchaîné aujourd'hui hier
aujourd'hui ce contrat la maison blanche
cela fait d'ailleurs selon les
spécialistes avec une rapidité
inhabituelle
alors on veut dire que le ton est à la
fois grave et ironique grave en raison
des conséquences qui auraient pu voir la
faire et puis ironique que en raison du
fiasco honteux de la manière dont s'est
terminée cette affaire selon les termes
mêmes de la pravda
alors avec côté alexis seyman on a dit
on a prétendu électeurs de l'urss que
peut-être les russes vont rester au
courant d'opérations à lester qu'est ce
qu'on pensait c'est une stupidité parce
que si nous étions au courant si moi je
le pense ou persuader pour mon
gouvernement que certainement nous
aurions fait impossible pour que cette
opération ne puisse pas avoir lieu à ce
propos je dis oui on prétend que
l'espagne après qu'il eut un brouillage
par lequel on a empêché les avions
d'atterrir alors c'est ce qui a provoqué
cet accident mais écoutez si les oies du
capitole ont sauvé et rome ce canard un
peu gros enfin lancé n'est ce pas par je
ne sais qui sera probablement pas les
américains du ridicule dans lequel il se
trouve alors l'impression que vos
réactions il s'avance quick est à la
fois voulait mesurer dans le fond est
très vive
sur la forme on a eu zéro du côté russe
on ne veut pas aggraver les choses
en aucun cas nous ne nous ne cherchons
pas à nous n'a bougé
chercher à envenimer quelques situations
que ce soit donc l'iran a commis un
impair en prenant des otages nous
l'avons condamné mais sans chercher à
envenimer les choses
mais les américains qui comptent une
opération malheureuse pour eux
malheureusement beaucoup de choses aussi
et là non plus nous cherchons en aucun
cas en venu mais la situation parce que
ce que nous voulons nous c'est avant
tout la détente ça c'est clair
nous allons revenir avec vous tout à
l'heure mais se sait et man mais nous
allons voir maintenant la situation en
politique intérieure américaine les
réactions des hommes politiques ont été
assez différente elles ont évolué depuis
hier l'un des jugements les plus
attendus sur l'échec de l'opération de
tabasse était celle du de l'ancien
président nixon les bosses chez check
s'est dit c'est un peu ce que pense
l'opinion américaine carter a eu raison
d'essayer
nous n'avons qu'un président et ça n'est
pas le moment de l'abandonner à 10 par
exemple monsieur de george bush un des
adversaires républicains de monsieur
carter et la pignon public retient
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait montrer le
drapeau faire quelque chose pour enfin
apporter la preuve que le géant
américain n'est pas paralysé une fois
encore c'est le réflexe patriotique qui
s'est déclenché alors qu'on est bien
loin de connaître comment aurait dû se
dérouler toute l'opération
un premier sondage nous a plant ce matin
que les américains dans une écrasante
majorité 88% continue de penser qu'il
faut soutenir carter pour la libération
des otages et fait étonnant peut-être
70% des américains reste en faveur d'une
nouvelle opération de sauvetage
le washington post et le new york times
dans leur des rites et éditoriales
affirme on peut regretter l'échec mais
pas la démarche l'attentât
you may dans ce même new york times des
voix se font plus critiques comme celle
de l'écrivain arthur schlesinger qui
demande
et bien maintenant que va-t-on faire
critique et analyse de monsieur ce temps
lui hoffman également qui est avec nous
et qui vous écoutent rue bériault vient
du seigneur frein est ce que cet échec
ne va pas favoriser pour vous là la
montée des faucons et des militaires qui
vont souhaiter peut-être un réarmement
des états unis en tous les cas le
développement de nouvelles armes
atomiques
très probablement oui mais pas tout de
suite parce que dans ce genre de cas on
avait déjà des exemples de la crise au
moment de la faire la bd des cochons de
la première tendance des américains de
se rassembler autour du président c'est
en train de se produire
ça va parce que je crois que d'ici
quelques semaines les voies deviendront
beaucoup plus critique les différents
candidats à la présidence se montreront
beaucoup plus féroce et je crois que ça
bénéficiera finalement ou républicain et
en particulier à monsieur regen est ce
que vous pensez pas que les échecs
répétés de la politique de monsieur
carter vont finalement conduire
l'america se renfermer un peu sur
elle-même à s'isoler
non certainement pas je crois qu'il n'ya
plus qu'en france qu'on pense qu'il
existe encore un isolationnisme aux
états unis même dans des conditions
comme celles-là non je crois que on aura
affaire à une politique beaucoup plus
agressive beaucoup plus militariste si
vous voulez mais c'est pas du tout la
même chose que l'isolationnisme
nous allons parler sera une politique
mondiale
une politique de guerre froide ils ont
évoqué tout de suite avec monsieur
maurice couve de murville les problèmes
des relations entre l'europe et les
états unis
comment vous les voyez vous ces
relations dans la mesure où vous voyez
bien que l'europe est un petit peu
stupéfaite et inquiète de la manière
dont la politique américaine est
conduite c'est évident vous avez défini
les les réactions normales d des
européens dans cette affaire la première
a été la stupéfaction parce qu'il s'y
attendait pas et qu'ensuite ça a été
l'échec lamentable que que l'on a connu
est ce que vous attendez une crise de
confiance vraiment entre les européens
et les américains écoutent et j'allais
dire la seconde réaction et la quiétude
mais l'inquiétude vise avant taz la
situation mondiale que les etats unis
eux mêmes c'est à dire quelles vont être
les conséquences de ce de ce coup manqué
alors pour ce qui est de des réactions
ou du conséquences dans les rapports
entre les états unis et les européens je
crois qu'il est encore trop tôt de
porter un jugement définitif il est
certain que ça va créer en europe
je dirais des sentiments divers il y a
des sentiments de solidarité qui sont
incontestables qui sont exprimés
d'ailleurs en beaucoup d'endroits y
compris et y compris la france
et puis il y a des sentiments de doute
les sentiments de doutes sur le
bien-fondé de la politique américaine
pas seulement le coup monté de
l'enlèvement des otages mais l'ensemble
de ce qui s'est passé depuis
la sphère de l'ambassade de tir mais
lorsqu'on est un exemple précis espagne
à 4 jours au début de la semaine les
mises affaires étrangères de l'europe
avait justement pris des mesures en vue
de sanctions contre l'iran à la demande
des états unis est soi disant pour
éviter des états unis ne prennent des
mesures militaires la face une aventure
militaire
ces mesures ont été décidées ces mesures
de sanction laventure militaire a quand
même eu est ce que vous croyez
finalement que les européens vont
continuer dans cette voie des sanctions
économiques
écoutez je pense que les européens vont
se poser des questions et les questions
qui a lieu de poser je trouve
parce qu'il faut toujours s'élever ou au
dessus des circonstances et des
incidents même quand ces incidents sont
aussi spectaculaire que celui là les
questions on peut se poser d'avancé à
quoi ça sert
est ce que ces sanctions sont utiles est
ce qu'elles ont la moindre efficacité et
on peut dire que si le gouvernement des
états unis avait pensé que ces sanctions
cette efficace il n'aurait pas eu besoin
de tentes et l'enlèvement des otages
il n'avait qu'à attendre que les
sanctions aboutissent à la libération
vous êtes contre les sanctions c'est une
manière c'est nous c'est que je pense
des questions et la seconde question
qu'on peut se poser si si si si ces
sanctions sont vraiment approprié parce
que après tout si les les pays européens
suivent les états unis cela veut dire
que l'ensemble du monde occidental
puisque le japon en fait partie et qu'il
est aussi associée à ces à cette
politique ça veut dire que l'ensemble du
monde occidental sera coupée tyran est
ce que c'est vraiment ce que l'on
cherche de jeter l'iran volens nolens
contraint ou ou ou de bonne volonté dans
les bras de l'union soviétique déjà nous
voyons que l'union soviétique vient de
conclure un contrat comme hier un accord
commercial avec l'iran
donnez entendu probablement de surcoûts
vieux merville est ce que vous pensez
que la crédibilité des relations entre
l'europe et les états unis est à ce
point entachées de suspicion répondrai
en deux points d'ailleurs parfaitement
contradictoire le premier c'est que la
position officielle des états unis qui
se défend fort bien c'est que
l'opération d'avant tier n'était pas une
invasion n'était même pas un blocus
naval qui est un acte de guerre c'était
une tentative pour évacuer les otages
américains étant donné comme le faisait
remarquer monsieur couve de murville que
les autres moyens y compris d'ailleurs
aussi la pure et simple négociation ne
menait à rien ou risquer de traîner en
longueur
la deuxième remarque c'est que sur le
fond je ne suis pas du tout en désaccord
avec les analyses de monsieur couve de
murville mais il faut aussi se rendre
compte du fait suivant les américains
pendant plusieurs semaines ont misé sur
la patience la prudence les négociations
il ya eu des espoirs sans doute excessif
au moment de la mission de monsieur
valdes à m et ensuite une fois que ces
espoirs sont retombées il a bien fallu
pour des raisons qui nous tiennent
d'ailleurs pas particulièrement à la
campagne électorale faire quelque chose
il ya eu une pression de l'opinion est
une sorte de de désespoir devant l'échec
des voix mais ton raisonnable mais trop
lente et je crois que c'est dans cette
espèce de deux cages que tourne pour
l'instant la politique américaine
je crois que finalement il faudra en
revenir en fait à la voie de la patience
pour toutes les raisons que
monsieur couve de murville a indiqué bon
retour à moscou maintenant avec monsieur
c'est zeman ccmt vous vous êtes ici oui
et est ce que vous y croyez encore à
cette détente finalement et à la voie de
la patience que je viens d'évoquer
monsieur ousmane absolument absolument
et la détente n'est pas compromise par
l'acte que vient de commettre quatre
fers en déclenchant cette opération en
iran il a été compromise si vous voulez
par toute la politique de café du rni
moi un peu la vôtre aussi
non je ne crois pas au contraire nous ne
cessons de tout faire pour que vous ayez
la détente même la maison georges bacou
ici nous sommes absolument persuadés
mais louis berry on veut parler de
l'afghanistan sissaoui à l'afghanistan
mais bon bah écoute effectifs et à notre
sujet évidemment là on va vous
connaissez très bien la position
spécifique tout à fait je n'ai rien à
redire là dessus je remercie alors
maintenant nous allons voir que samuel
puisards qui est un avocat international
qui est depuis longtemps sur la détente
et je vais vous poser la même question
qu'à monsieur seleman puisque vous
croyez vous encore à la lutte en
voulaient c'est quand même encourageant
de voir moscou et washington
simultanément moins encourageantes au
sujet de la détente mais il ne faut pas
s'attacher aux mots il faut rétablir la
coexistence il faut désamorcer
l'apocalypse est ce que vous voyez une
alternative
nous courons leiris de no low cost
thermonucléaire et croyez moi j'ai déjà
vu dans ma vie une fois tout un monde
s'effondrer alors aujourd'hui la machine
militaire marche très mal est ce que
vous pensez que les règles du jeu
internationales sont pas maintenant
escamoté ou faux c est ce qu on the path
pas voter parce que nous voyons qu'hélas
quincaillerie militaire est rouillée et
parfois je me demande si le cerveau
militaires ne sont pas rouillé aussi
alors les règles de jeu
il faut regarder la réalité comprendre
la réalité l'union soviétique et une
très grande puissance militaire ce vrai
mais elle souffre d'une très grande
faiblesse industrielles agricoles
elle n'arrive pas à nourrir son peuple
et elle manquera dans les années 80 du
pétrole
c'est un fait essentiel et alors elle
est attirée vers le golfe persique
parce qu'elle est obligée de ça pour y
visionner un pétrole d'approvisionner
l'europe de l'est et les cuba et la
finlande
et voilà là c'est une tout autre lecture
d'une tension que des tonnes ça c'est un
facteur de tension mais alors il faut
chercher un moyen de des temps alors
comment je vais vous donner un exemple
si vous acceptez qu'elle est vrai
problème sont économiques et politiques
et qui on ne peut pas trouver une
solution avec des moyens militaires
et alors il faut se poser la question
est ce qui s est pétrole qui existe un
sibérie dans la sibérie de l'est de
l'ouest et ce qu'il faut vraiment
refuser à soviétique la technologie qui
existe aux états unis pour ouvrir le jce
mans il me semble que c'est dans notre
intérêt des données soviétique la
possibilité devait développer ces
pétroles et c'est ça qui est très
important c'est ce et je suis même un
peu obsédé par ça j'ai écrit un livre
que j'ai appelé le sens de l'espoir
parce que j'ai vu beaucoup de sang versé
dans ma vie et cette semaine on a de
nouveau commencé à verser du sang il
faut trouver un moyen de transformer ce
sens un espoir bien messieurs je vous
remercie pour rapport à cette édition
spéciale léon zitrone pour les dernières
d'information eh bien demain c'est
dimanche donc tiercé à longchamp dans le
prix de notre confrère week-end de 1280
parpaings les pronostics de pierrette
brès le 3 seront beaux poulains de
bonnes classes le capteur nibelung de
succès l'an passé le cese fabricius cinq
fois à l'arrivée le divise beau château
de victoires récent peu 11 litres lake
très régulier puis viennent le bluesman
berry le vide jeune prince et le cette
troupe qui trouva la météo et vient de
la manche orientale on
renault reste si elle souvent très
nuageux et il pleuvra un peu le matin
mais des éclaircies se développeront
d'après midi les températures varieront
peu et sur le reste du pays le temps
sera souvent ensoleillé avec des vents
faibles et températures en hausse
le dernier journal où sera présenté par
gérard holtz tout à l'heure et je vous
rappelle que l'équipe d'antenne 2
diffusera après demain lundi de moscou
antenne 2010 le journal télévisé de 20h
notre magazine habituels du lundi soir
question de temps comment vit-on en
union soviétique en ce moment quelles
sont les réactions des soviétiques aux
évènements dramatiques actuelle nous
venons d'en avoir avec mais ce ces mêmes
ou par exemple leurs réactions à la non
participation de plusieurs grands pays
aux jeux olympiques que c'est le
soviétique moyen de ce qui se passe sur
la planète c'est ce que vous verrez en
suivant une série de reportages
présentée par jacques bouchard et toute
notre équipe et qui seront présentées
par jean pierre elkabbach et patrick
poivre d'arvor votre édition est
terminée
bonsoir merci